The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In the previous lectures,
we discussed the general
continuum mechanics formulations
that we use in
nonlinear finite element
analysis.
And we also derived some
element matrices.
In this lecture, I'd like
to discuss this
you the truss element.
The truss element is a very
interesting element and a very
important element.
It is important because it's
used in the analysis of many
truss structures and also
in the analysis of cable
structures.
It's an interesting element to
study from a theoretical point
of view because we can use the
general continuum mechanics
equations analytically and
derive directly the finite
element equations and the finite
matrices corresponding
to truss element.
These are derived
in closed form.
We can study these matrices
and get some insight, some
physical insight, into what
really these individual terms
in the continuum mechanics
equations mean.
We want to study in this lecture
the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
And in the next lecture, the
total Lagrangian formulation.
I mentioned earlier in a
lecture that these two
formulations really reduce to
exactly the same matrices
provided certain
transformations routes are followed.
And for the truss element, we
can actually very nicely
analytically demonstrate
that all is true.
So let us study now the updated
Lagrangian formulation
and later on the total
Lagrangian
formulation of the element.
The assumptions that we are
using for the truss element
are that the stresses are
transmitted only in the
direction normal to
the cross section.
The stress is constant over
And the cross sectional area
remains constant doing
deformations.
Of course, these first two
assumptions here are those
that we are also using
in linear analysis.
This we add now as an
assumption, meaning that we
really only consider small
strain problems.
We will consider large rotation,
large displacement,
but only small strain
problems.
Here we have a typical
element.
We align that to another truss
element with the x1 in its
original configuration.
And the elemental goes through
large deformations as you can
see and the large
rotation, theta.
This is node 1, originally
here, moves there.
This node 2, originally
Notice that the length of the
element is L in its original
configuration and it
is also L in the
configuration at time t.
We use Young's modulus, an
elastic material, in other
words, we assume for
the element.
The cross sectional area is A.
And once again, we also use
the fact that the element lies
in the x1, x2 space.
The same kind of deviation that
I'm now following through
could, of course, also be
generalized to the three
dimensional case, in other
words were you have three
axes, x3 being included.
But all of the relevant
information, particularly the
physical insight that we want to
get from this deviation, is
very well obtained by just
considering element lying in
the x1, x2 plane and moving
in that plane.
If we now look at the
deformations of the element,
we can see that at times 0
it was here once again.
The displacement off node 2
is into the x1 direction
signified by this symbol here,
time t, u, into the 1
direction at node 2.
Into the 2 direction,
we have u2.
The lower 2 means 2 direction,
2 of course being upwards.
The upper 2 means node 2.
The t, once again,
means at time t.
If you look at the left node
here, node 1, that one moves
this way and that way.
We use, of course, a
similar symbolism
to denote this movement.
So this is the deformation from
time 0 to times t given
by these nodal point
displacements.
Now from time t to time t plus
delta t, we obtain am addition
deformation.
And that additional deformation
is given by these
displacements, at node 2 here
and at node 1 here.
Notice that, in other words,
from time t to times t plus
delta t, the truss has moved
from the red configuration to
the blue configuration.
Of course, note that these
displacements are measured in
the stationary coordinate
frame.
I made a big point in the
earlier lectures out of the
fact that the coordinate frame
remains stationary and the
elements move through the
coordinate frame.
Of course, what we're interested
in doing is to
calculate, in the finite
element solution, these
incremental displacements.
We assume that the
configuration
at time t is known.
We want to calculate the
new configuration.
That means we want to calculate
these incremental
displacements.
And we achieve that by setting
up the appropriate matrices
for the element.
Well to develop the appropriate
matrices for the
updated Lagrangian formulation
which I would like to discuss
in this lecture, it is best
to introduce an auxiliary
coordinate frame.
And that auxiliary coordinate
frame is one that is aligned
with one axis along
the element.
We introduce x1 curl
and x2 curl.
The curl always meaning body
aligned coordinate frame.
Notice that this is now the
rotation here that the element
has undergone.
And of course, we really want to
get the stiffness matrix in
the x1, x2 frame.
x2, of course, being
perpendicular to x1, not shown
on this viewgraph, but shown
on the earlier viewgraphs.
We know that if we have
calculated the matrices in
this curl coordinate frame, the
body attached coordinate
frame, we very easily can
transform to the stationary
coordinate frame.
So let us now concentrate on
finding the K-matrix, the
F-vector, corresponding
to this body
attached coordinate frame.
To do so, we look back to our
continuum mechanics equations
that we developed in
earlier lectures.
Here we have the basic continuum
mechanics equation,
the principal of virtual work
written for the update
Lagrangian formulation in the
curled coordinate frame, see
that curl there.
And this was the starting point
for the development off
all of the equations that we're
using in the update
Lagrangian formulation.
The linearization resided
in this equation.
And we talked about this
equation quite a bit.
Except, of course, we did not
have to curls there because we
were talking about the x1, x2,
x3 uncurled coordinate frame.
Now we're talking about this
curled coordinate frame, so I
simply put a curl on there.
But otherwise, the terms
are identical.
Because for the truss as I
state earlier the only
non-zero stress is the stress
along the length of the truss
which acts normally to the cross
section of the truss, we
can simplify this general
equation to this equation.
The only non-zero stress
is tau curl 1 1.
The only strain that we call
stress, only small strain that
we call stress, is e curl 1 1.
Of course a t on the left-hand
side because it's referred to
as the configuration
at time t.
So this very general equation
reduces to a much simpler
equation already
as shown here.
What we are out now to do is to
evaluate these quantities
here and there using the finite
element interpolation.
First let us now look at what
are some of the terms that we
easily can identify.
We identify this tensile
term here to be
simply Young's modulus.
This stress term to be simply
the force in the truss divided
by the cross sectional area.
The volume of the truss
is given here.
Notice, once again, the length
of the truss is assumed to be
constant, therefore we only
consider small strain
conditions, I mentioned
that earlier.
If we now use this information
in the general equation, we
directly arrive at this
equation here.
You simply substitute and you
will see immediately that
these are the terms.
Of course, what we now have to
evaluate are these curled
terms here.
To proceed, we identify that
the e curl 1 1, the linear
strain term, is simply given
by the linear strain
displacement matrix with a curl
on it times the nodal
point displacement vector.
These are the nodal point
displacements.
There are four such
displacements because we have
two nodes and two displacements
per node.
Notice that I have a curl here
signifying that we're talking
about the curled coordinate
frame.
And there's a hat on top off
that curl as you can see here.
That hat means these are
discrete nodal point
displacements.
This term here is evaluated
via that term.
Notice that we construct the
BNL in such a way that this
right-hand side is equal
to that left-hand side.
I mentioned that also in the
earlier lectures for the two
dimensional and the
three dimensional
finite element cases.
Well the vector of nodal point
displacements, this vector
here, is listed out here.
Notice it contains the four
displacements that I referred
to earlier.
And these are the displacements,
u curl
1 1, u curl 2 1.
This upper 1 always denoting
nodal point, the lower 1 and 2
meaning coordinate directions.
Similarly for these two terms.
To evaluate now these terms,
we recognize that the total
strain, the total incremental
Green-Lagrange strain I should
say, is given by this
relationship here from our
general continuum mechanics
equation.
The linear strain term
is given here.
And the nonlinear strain
term is the rest.
The rest meaning taking this
total, subtracting the linear
one, you're left
with that one.
And once again, these
expressions are directly
obtained by just taking the
general continuum mechanics
equations and varying the
indices the way you want to
see them varied.
1 1, for i and j, if you
would refer back.
And k, the k that used earlier
goes over 1 and 2 in this
particular case.
In a three dimensional case,
of course, you would have k
also going to 3.
The variation on this term
resides directly in this
expression.
And we notice that this
expression can also be written
in matrix form.
One row vector times
one column vector.
It is convenient to work now
with this matrix form because
we want to bring it into a
form BNL transposed BNL.
Before doing so, let us identify
one important point,
namely that the displacement
derivatives are
constant along the truss.
The reason for it is that we
have only two nodes and these
two notes can only specify
a linear variation and
displacement between the two
nodes, meaning a linear
variation along the truss and
the displacement derivatives
are therefore constant.
For example, this displacement
derivative is simply obtained
by taking the difference in the
nodal point displacements,
of course, in direction 1
because we're talking about 1
here, over the length L.
So this is directly obtained
as u curl 1 comma 1.
Similarly, we also evaluate u
curl 2, 1 and you see the
lower part here gives
us that expression.
Of course, the upper row here
is nothing else than the
rewriting of that equation.
If you rewrite this equation in
matrix form, you directly
obtain this relationship.
Or another check would be simply
takes this vector,
multiply this matrix by that
vector, and the upper part of
that multiplication will
directly be this result.
If we now use this information,
we directly
extract the BL matrix, which of
course links up the linear
strain increment with the nodal
point displacements.
Here there is a small error.
Let me just point it out.
This bracket, of course, should
go to there because the
B matrix does not contain
the nodal point
displacement vector.
It only goes up to there.
Because the e curl 1 1 is equal
to B matrix times the
nodal point displacement
vector.
Similarly we can write
now the variation in
eta 1 1 in this form.
Notice that this part here
captures this amount and this
part here captures
that amount.
This one, of course, we had
already derived earlier.
We just plug it in now.
With this information
we can not directly
develop the k matrices.
We notice that the linear strain
stiffness matrix is
obtained from this expression.
And here you have it.
You simply substitute for these
terms and obtain this
matrix, much in the
same way as we are
dealing in linear analysis.
The nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix, that's the one we want
to look at next, is obtained
from this relationship.
And we simply now substitute
what we have derived for this
term and directly obtain
this expression here.
And what's under this blue
bracket, of course, is our
nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix.
Finally, the force vector is
obtained from this expression.
And you, once again, simply
plug in and obtain this
expression here where what's
under the blue
is the force vector.
The beauty is that we have
started with a fairly
complicated continuum
mechanics equation.
We have specialized it to the
truss element, recognizing
that only certain terms really
need to be included or are
included in this particular
case.
We have evaluated them in a
fairly simple, straightforward
manner, plugged in, and obtained
now matrices that can
of course be analytically
evaluated the way that they
have it done.
And now we can in fact even
think about these matrices and
try to physically interpret
their meaning.
We will do that just now.
However, before getting into
that, we want to get back to
one point, namely that we have
sued so far a curled
coordinate system.
And as we mentioned earlier, we
will have to transform from
that curled coordinate system
to the stationary global
coordinate system.
That is achieved by this
transformation.
Notice that the curled
displacements are nothing else
than transformation matrix
times the uncurled
displacement.
This transformation matrix
is very well
known from linear analysis.
It simply transforms
displacement from one
coordinate system
into another.
This is the one that holds
anywhere along the element for
the continuous displacement.
But it also holds
at the nodes.
So if we apply that relationship
at the nodes, be
directly obtain this
transformation here.
The curled displacements at the
nodes are given in terms
of the transformation matrix
times the uncurled
displacement at the nodes.
Of course, we want to get the
matrix expressions related to
this uncurled displacement
vector.
Well having obtained this
relationship, we go back to
the basic equations, recognizing
that this part
here is coming from the linear
strain stiffness matrix.
We substitute for u curl,
the uncurled vectors
with the T's in front.
There is a transpose
appearing now here.
This capital transpose has to
be there because there's a
transpose there.
And what's in here underlined
in red is the linear strain
stiffness matrix of the element
corresponding to the
stationery global coordinate
system.
We proceed much the same way
for the nonlinear strain
stiffness matrix.
And what's in here now is what
we want to get, the nonlinear
strain stiffness matrix
corresponding to the global
stationary coordinate frame.
Same thing holds of course
for the F-vector.
And here we have the F-vector
now in the uncurled global
stationary coordinate frame.
So it's really this part, that
part, and this part that we're
using in our finite element
analysis when we assemble
truss elements into a global
assemblage of truss elements.
Performing the indicated matrix
multiplications gives
this expression here.
In fact, this is the same
stiffness matrix that we use
in linear analysis when we
have an element that is
oriented at an angle theta
to the global x-axis, the
horizontal x-axis.
So you might have very well
seen this matrix before.
The nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix looks this way.
Notice there is a tP over
L and then these terms.
Of course, it's also
symmetric.
And this is the matrix
corresponding to the global
coordinate frame now.
We notice immediately that this
matrix is in fact the
same matrix that we already had
evaluated in the curved
coordinate frame.
We will get back to
that just now.
The F-vector comes
out to be this.
Let's now look at these
terms physically.
Here we have a single truss
element pinned at the
left-hand side.
And a load R is applied to that
truss at the other end.
Of course, this direction of
the load must be along the
truss element.
Or rather the truss element
aligns its direction so that
it balances this load
that is applied.
The internal force is tP.
tP balances tR.
And tP, of course, acts along
the truss element.
Now if you look at this node
here, node 2, we notice
immediately that this tR vector
can be decomposed.
Or this tR can be decomposed
into tR cosine theta along
this axis and tR sin theta
along that axis.
P is acting here and P can also
be decomposed as shown.
Now if we look here, we find
therefore that the tR vector
corresponding to the global
coordinate system contains
these two entries shown here.
And the tF from our earlier
viewgraph at node 2 was indeed
simply this part.
We notice therefore that tR is
equal to tF as show here or tR
minus ttF equal to 0.
And that is, of course, what
has to hold when we satisfy
equilibrium at that node.
So we have a nice
interpretation of this F-vector.
And in fact, we can see that our
arithmetic of getting that
F-vector has been correct.
Let's look now at the KNL
matrix, the nonlinear strain
stiffness matrix.
We already pointed out earlier
that the KNL in the uncurled
frame was equal to the KNL
in the curled frame.
And we can ask ourself, of
course, why is that so?
Well the reason is
the following.
Let's look again at this truss
element pinned here and we
look at node 2, then we see that
this vector here, which
is by Pythagoras the component
or the resultant vector of
these two displacements,
has this length.
Now this length can be evaluated
as shown here.
Because the derivatives are
constants, we discussed that
earlier, we can write this
derivative squared plus that
derivative squared, square root
out of it, times L, being
equal to that.
But then we recognize that
what we're seeing here is
nothing else than that term
there, in other words, our
nonlinear strain increment.
Which in this particular case
we can see, for the given
displacement is constant and
independent of the coordinate
frame used.
And that is really the reason
why the KNL matrix is constant
for any coordinate frame
that we are using.
Let us now try to understand
what the elements in the KNL
matrix physically mean.
They, in fact, give the change
in force, the required change
in the externally applied
force, when
the element is rotated.
Here we have an element at time
t, once again fixed at
the left end, and subjected
to a force tR.
Of course, this force tR
is balanced by the
internal force tP.
Let us now impose a displacement
such that the
element rotates about
this point.
We reach the configuration
at time t plus delta t by
imposing this displacement
here, which we
denote u curl 2 2.
Now in this configuration,
a new force has
to act on this element.
And this new force, denoted
as t plus delta
tR, is shown here.
Here we have the force
t plus delta tR.
Notice it is aligned with the
red element at time t plus
delta t now.
The change in the force from
configuration t to t plus
delta t is given
by this vector.
And the element in that vector
can be calculated by taking
moment equilibrium
about this point.
We do just that right here.
This is the equation of moment
equilibrium about the fixed
point of the truss.
Notice that, of course, this
displacement is small.
And from this, we directly
obtain that delta R is given
as shown here on the
right-hand side.
And this is actually the entry
4, 4 of the KNL matrix.
Now the same information is
also expressed here on the
right-hand side where we have
written the delta R as a
matrix product of KNL times u
hat being equal to t plus
delta tR minus tR.
So this completes our discussion
of the finite
element matrices of the truss
element corresponding to the
updated Lagrangian
formulation.
In the next lecture, we will
actually discuss the total
Lagrangian formulation
of the truss element.
And we will find that
identically the same matrices
are obtained as in the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
That will be a very interesting
theoretical point,
as well as practical point.
Let us now look at an example
of using the truss element.
And the example is a
simple one, and yet
quite practical one.
We will analyze a prestressed
cable.
The cable has a length 2L.
At the midpoint, a load
of 2 tR is supplied.
The Young's modulus of the
cable is E, the cross
sectional area of
the cable is A.
We can model one half of the
cable because of symmetry
conditions as shown down here.
Notice that, of course, we
assume the transverse
displacement to be small, the
angle therefore to be small,
because we assume that the
length of the cable element
remains the same.
In other words, it does not
change from time zero to time
t to time t plus delta
t and so on.
Using the U.L. Formation, we
obtain directly from the
general matrices that we
discussed us now, this
equation here.
Which gives the tangent
stiffness matrix times the
displacement increment equal to
the externally applied load
minus the nodal point force
corresponding to the internal
element stress, the internal
element force tP, of course,
in this case.
Notice that this is the
equilibrium equation that
carries us from time t to
time t plus delta t.
We would iterate on this, of
course, introducing an
iteration counter here on
the right-hand side.
We have discussed all that in
earlier lectures to obtain an
accurate solution for time t
plus delta t, but these are
some details that we don't
need to look at now.
For the moment, let's just look
at this equation here, in
which we imply basically a
simple step by step forward
incrementation of load
without iteration.
In practice once again, we would
actually iterate to make
sure that we are satisfying
equilibrium at the end
of each time step.
Of particular interest is the
configuration at time 0.
And there we recognized that
the linear strain stiffness
matrix up here is 0.
And that's all we have in terms
of stiffness is the
nonlinear strain stiffness.
And that is expressed in
this equation here.
Notice that therefore if P0 is
equal to 0, in other words,
there's no prestress in the
cable, then initially it has
no stiffness.
Of course, this element here,
let's look at it here at time
t, this element here will
increase ad the deformations
increase because tP
will increase.
And this element here will
also increase as the
deformations increase.
And in fact, this is expressed
once more here.
This total matrix will in
fact be increasing.
We say the cable stiffens
and the load is applied.
If theta becomes very large, in
fact if as theta goes to 90
degrees, the stiffness becomes
quite large and the stiffness
approaches as theta goes to 90
degrees EA over L. Now this,
of course, is rather theoretical
because we assume
in our formulation that the
length remains constant and
therefore that the deformations
are small, as I
pointed out earlier.
Let us now look at the actual
load displacement curve that
is calculated for this
particular truss structure,
which is really a cable
structure, we could look also
at it as a trust structure
because it is made up of two
truss elements.
Here we have the deflection
plotted.
And here we have the applied
force plotted for
a particular case.
Notice that L is 120 inches,
A is 1 square inch.
Notice that the maximum
displacement we're looking at
here is about 2 inches.
So 2 inches over the length, 120
inches, means really small
deformations.
But notice the stiffening effect
shown by the increase
in the slope of this curve.
We can actually show the
stiffness matrix components as
a function of the
applied load.
And this is a very interesting
viewgraph.
Here we see that at 0 load,
the only stiffness that is
there is given by KNL.
We pointed that out
already earlier.
KL is equal to 0.
As the load increases,
KNL increases as
shown by the blue curve.
As a load increases, also KL
increases as shown here.
And the sum of these two curves,
of course, gives us
the red curve.
And the red curve is the total
tangent stiffness matrix.
At any particular applied force,
we can directly read
off the stiffness
corresponding to
that applied force.
Or, more naturally, we would
of course look for the
corresponding displacement.
In other words, at a particular
applied force, we
have a corresponding
displacement.
And for that corresponding
displacement, we
would have a stiffness.
Of course, these curves are
directly obtained from the
expression that I just
showed you earlier.
Well, this brings us to the
end of this lecture.
In the next lecture then, as I
pointed out already, I'd like
to look with you at the total
Lagrangian formulation of the
truss element.
And as I mentioned earlier, we
will find something very
interesting, namely that
reducing all of these complex
continuum mechanics equations
down to what we really need
for the truss element, we will
find that the same matrices in
a total Lagrangian formulation
are obtained as in the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
Thank you very much for
your attention.